i'd like to call this meeting of the
i would like to ask everyone in the
audience to remain quiet so that the
committee may conduct their business
efficiently
this meeting is being live streamed
i ask the committee to utilize your
microphones
anytime you are speaking
both for the benefit of our remote
viewers
and for the people here in the room to
hear you
overflow rooms are available for the
audience to view this meeting
they are located in rooms 202
and 205 207
which are down the hallway on this floor
they will have a live live fee of this
meeting on a television
again thank you for being here today
and please help us get through our
business by remaining quiet throughout
the proceedings
please be sure to turn your phones to
silent or vibrate mode
thank you
our first order of business are the
minutes
from the september
17th meeting
we had a correction to those
and i believe
that has been made
could i have a motion to accept the
minutes so moved
okay
senator guida moved and senator
rosenwald seconded point of order yes uh
should the motion not be to approve as
amended as correct yeah as amended
thank you okay thank you
all those in favor
one
two three four five six seven in favor
opposed
i'm not opposed but i was not here at
that meeting so i'm staying
at that point all right
now we move to the october 22nd 2021
meeting
uh
okay represent senator d'alessandro
makes a motion to approve
second
second by senator guida
are there any comments questions
seeing none
uh please raise your hand if you're in
favor
nine in favor opposed
none
okay
uh the um
the
legislative
performance audit oversight committee
has
made a recommendation to us for approval
of a performance topic
licensing processing and procedures
for the mental health workforce
this is at
oplc
so
can i have a motion to i would so move
madam chair
thank you
sender guida senator guyda moves and
senator d'alessandro seconds
all those in favor please raise your
hand
one two three four five
six seven eight nine
nine in favor
uh representative edwards are you voting
yes
okay thank you
okay on tab four
uh there has been a request
to remove fis
this
by
senator rosenwald
so
if i could have someone from
madam chair yes um do we need to have
the door to the hallway open there's a
excuse uh it
excuse me if you want to hear
you can go to
you might try room
205 207
okay
senator roosevelt you had some questions
on this
i did thank you madam chair
um
this
question applies about this item and and
the later item uh the late item
my question is who
sees the test results
both within the state and does the
federal government
have access to any test results
thank you senator roosevelt um who sees
the results so the way these work is you
have a take-home test you do a saliva in
a little tube you spit in the tube you
send it back in a sealed envelope
and it goes to a laboratory the
laboratory processes it and then
notifies the individual of their result
the department of health and human
services is also notified it is com it
is a communicable disease that is one of
the diseases covid that gets reported
directly to us that's how we do our case
counts these are not reported to the
federal government as identifiable
tests but we do
submit
senator guida thank you madam chair
does the department maintain individual
data on each of these tests as it comes
back positive correct yes we maintain
individual data we maintain individual
line lists much like we do with the
other lists of reportable communicable
diseases to the state thank you
senator daniels
thank you
how are these tests administered are
they on a voluntary basis where somebody
would have to ask for it or is the
department going to be out there
promoting it uh through schools or some
other
medium to to get to the people
great um thank you for that question so
these are completely voluntary no one is
forced to take a test we are making them
available potentially in places like
schools so that people who are um who
children who have symptoms or even
beforehand parents can have that so that
it's ready to go if their child is
symptomatic they can do the testing in
the convenience of their own home the
way it works is you get a little kit um
you may have the option of doing a
zoomed visit with the with a health care
provider but you don't need to do that
but if you have questions on how to do
the self-administration how to spit in
the little tube it offers that ability
to have someone walk through that with
you but you don't have to do it and then
as i noted to senator rosenwald you pack
up the test you put it in an envelope
you send it to the laboratory then the
laboratory notifies the individual of
the result
i understand the problem with the sound
in the remote rooms
is that we are not talking close enough
to the microphone to be heard
so if you could
set your microphone on the
side of your book
and speak directly into it when
you
want to speak
are there any further questions on fis
move the item
okay thank you
all right senator rosenwald makes the
motion
and senator d'alessandro seconds madam
chair i had a question oh i'm
i'm sorry i thought excuse me thank you
thank you um
will there be any efforts by the
department to promote testing
through the schools
well we will certainly make people aware
that that option is open but schools
this is also voluntary on the par on the
basis of the schools the schools do not
have to participate if they don't want
to we similarly have other very
voluntary testing processes that we do
through schools but districts make that
decision for themselves
thank you okay
okay this is a
motion to approve on
21-352
yes
clerk voces
representative irf
yes
i can't read and talk at the same time
okay
senator daniels yes
senator morse yes
senator gaida yes
senator rosenwald yes
senator d'allesandro yes
madam chair the vote is 10
in favor
vote is 10 in favor thank you very much
uh could i have a motion to approve
all of the other consent items in tab
four move
all
all those in favor please raise your
hand
ten zero
thank you
i would
fis-21334
all right uh could i have a motion
this consent item i'm so moved thank you
senator gaida second
senator d'alessandro seconds
all those in favor please raise your
hand
tab six is one item on consent
three eight four fis twenty one three
eight four
do i have a motion to approve this item
madam chair is it three four eight or
three eight four three four three four
eight
twenty one three four sorry
twenty one dyslexia right here twenty
one three four eight
um all those in favor
oh i'm sorry
senator guida did you move that motion
no i just called oh okay
all right senator d'alessandro do i have
a second
second
okay
senator daniels
seconds
all those in favor please raise your
hand
10-0
in tab seven
uh the department of education
has asked that we
that that they withdraw
fis-21322
and representative senator rosenwald
asked that we remove
no no it was i'm sorry madam chair was
department of health and human services
okay that's fine i i had both of them
but oh okay so we will not remove three
two five
i don't think so
okay um
uh is uh senator rosenwald asked to
remove 336
okay
so
could i ask
hhs to come back to the
table
good morning could you please uh which i
didn't do last time state for the record
your name
karen rounds chief financial officer
thank you
commissioner lori shibbonnette dhhs
henry littman medicaid director
thank you very much senator roosevelt
thank you madam chair good morning
um i understand these are the extra
federal medicaid match funds
and my question is
last fiscal
department
lapsed
tens of millions of dollars
of general funds
that were supplanted by this extra
federal money
is the department planning to do that
again
this fiscal year or considering
so
we don't
purposefully try to lapse
these dollars
we did try to accept what we
could estimate we were going to receive
last fiscal year
one of the issues that
i have still not been able to resolve
financially in the department is
estimating revenue
we are finally at a place that we
estimate expenditures extremely well
every area the department does it the
same way
but revenues are a little bit more
complicated
we just
started a process to issue an rfp
to
be able to do that better in the coming
biennium
so
i can't tell you for sure that we won't
still lapse some revenue but we are
attempting in the best way that we have
available to us right now
to estimate the enhanced fmap and accept
it into the budget
yes go ahead thank you
the medicaid caseloads are still really
high
because of the extended public health
did we account for that in our
budget
did we appropriate enough to cover all
of the extra spending
which would allow you to lapse this
revenue
so
no we appropriated the additional
expenditures through 1231 i believe and
so that's why we're accepting these
funds which are creating an
appropriation to continue to pay for
those
thank you
seeing none
clerk oh i need a motion
okay thank you
senator rose i didn't have my microphone
on yeah that's okay senator rosenwald
makes the motion and
seconds
okay
21-336
representative edwards
yes
clerk votes yes
representative erf yes
senator daniels yes
senator
morse yes
senator guida yes
senator rosenwald yes
senator de la sandra
yes representative umberger yes
i'm sure the vote is 10-0
thank you very much 10-0
could i have a motion on
to
approve the remainder of the items in
tab 7
senator d'alessandro
second
seconded by senator rosenwald am i going
too fast
okay
all those in favor please raise your
hand
uh
10-0 thank you
could i have a motion to
accept
342 on the consent calendar remove the
item
thank you senator d'alessandro
okay all those in favor of
moving uh
fis-21 340
ten zero thank you
we now move on to
um
could i have a motion to accept this on
the consent calendar
thank you
all those in favor please raise your
hand
um
representative umberger has asked for
the removal of
fis-324 department of education
fish
hi could you please state your name
good morning i'm mackenzie snow division
sorry just pull the microphone towards
you and speak directly into it thank you
representative umberger i'm
snow division director of learner
support at the new hampshire department
of education
tma vallencourt cfo for the department
my question was
how are the
non-public schools
going to receive this
these dollars
thank you so i i think for context it's
helpful to understand that this is a
second iteration of the ian's program
eans one or carissa eens
what was just recently administered
and under all there is a second
tranchaphones called r-beans so it will
be administered substantially similar to
carissa ins the non-public schools that
are selected to participate
must be demonstrate their eligibility
and proactively apply they must
demonstrate their eligibility by showing
a substantial proportion of students who
are low income as well
significant impact of the covid19
pandemic the agency submitted an
application to the u.s department of
education with metrics for those these
two criteria which was recently approved
and we received the funds
on 10 25.
so the non-public schools will in fact
have an application process that they
need to go through that's correct okay
thank you uh could i have a motion oh
i'm sorry
thanks madam chair could you tell us how
many schools are likely to receive these
funds
so there were 48 non-public schools
deemed eligible and chosen and who chose
to participate in carissa ins but again
eligibility is based on their
self-reported data in their applications
so that gives us a guide post but
that number could be different
for our beans
thanks thanks madam chair are there any
further questions said d'alessandro
thank you madam chair
first of all thanks so much for you for
coming
but it's it seems there are a couple of
things here that
senator
well you're on but you're not close
enough
okay you're good
there are a couple of things on here
that that give me pause because of the
fact that they're an ongoing expense
that's going to have to be maintained
for example improving ventilation
systems
those are going to have to be maintained
over a long period of time
are they not
so that that is an explicitly federally
allowable use
and of course these funds are only
available for obligation through the end
of the performance period so their
federal funds when they run out they run
out
and that's the same situation with
leasing additional space
it seems to me once you've made it a
decision to lease additional space isn't
there a contractual relationship that's
usually associated with that that
extends over a period of time or is all
are is all of this done on an annual
basis so that period of time must be
within the performance period and for
our beans that's through federal fiscal
year 24.
so the space
that you indicated is very uncommon
nationwide and in new hampshire in
particular
it's typically to facilitate for social
distancing in classrooms but again that
could only be
utilized through the performance period
in carissa ends we saw the the vast
majority of expenditures around
items like
ppe
just one further question
but but these things have an ongoing
situation
and if you've made a commitment to do it
for a limited time what happens
when that time runs out
so if
there are additional needs in response
to the kova 19 pandemic
after the performance period of our
beans expires then those would not be
supported by existing federal funds
thank you madam chairman you're quite
welcome are there any other questions
on
21 324 yes senator gaiden
thank you madam chair
thank you for your excellent
presentation by the way thank you um
is this the same program or a program
equivalent to it available to our public
schools
so this is a separate program from that
serving public schools so in the first
package cares in 2020 there was a
requirement as there is with esea
programs and ida programs for public
schools to provide equitable services to
non-public school students and teachers
from their allocation
in
in carissa and arp the congress decided
to create a separate program that is
directly administered by state education
agencies as opposed to having
a portion a proportionate share of the
non-public schools allocations spent on
participating non-public schools and in
fact i think it's helpful to note that
school districts in the state have
received over 540 million dollars across
six different programs and these three
different legislative packages
assistant with the feedback that we've
received from school districts thank you
very much
seeing none will the clerk call the role
please
madam chair this is item 21-324
representative edwards yes
clerk votes yes representative earth yes
representative leicester yes
senator daniels yes
senator morse yes
senator gaida yes
senator rosenwald yes
senator d'alessandro yes representative
umberger yes
madam chair of the vote is
um
fis
fis257
represent
our three
thank you
senator rosenwald yes i would like to
remember okay no problem
um could someone from
hello
good morning
would you please uh
introduce yourself taylor caswell the
governor's office for
just
for emergency but even recovery sorry
yeah uh make sure you speak directly
into the mic because understood okay
thank
you and
chase hageman deputy director at gopher
okay thank you very much go ahead
senator thank you madam chair i have a
number of questions on this item if
you'll indulge me i will thank you um
first i'd
curious how you arrived at the amount
of 17 million and change
how
how did that number
certainly uh senator i i think what we
were aiming for is to be able to
launch a pilot program where we would
see somewhere between one thousand and
fifteen hundred
student
take advantage of a program such as this
uh and that that total comes to around
15 million dollars roughly speaking
because there would be an average there
and the remaining funds would be used
over the course of the three or four
years of the program for to administer
the program
allocate a portion of the funds
to individuals who are most affected
and so my question is why only a portion
what portion and why not a hundred
percent being the portion certainly i
think that the idea that we had with
this program was sort of twofold one is
to put
the bulk of the funding so let's say i
think it was 10 million dollars that
would be eligible for individuals who
are at 80 percent or lower of the uh of
the area media income
and that would be the first component of
the program that would be launched and
made available
the second remaining amount
of roughly let's say 5 million dollars
would be
launched later in the summer and the
target would be students that are
graduating this coming spring
and giving them incentive to stay in the
state and take jobs
in with new hampshire employers
thank you and um
what are the industries that you're
proposing to run this
program in and how are they arrived at
so at this point this program is seen as
sort of a foundational component of our
workforce recruitment effort and so we
have not specifically designated any
industries or any sectors here uh we are
we're aware of the fact that there
really is no industry or sector in new
hampshire that is not
experiencing a labor shortage right now
um
thank you
so you're probably aware that we have a
state loan repayment program
that we allocate general funds to
for health care workers this budget
appropriated about half as much money to
it
as the last budget
but we could
all
all the requests
to what extent will health care
get the money
that you're proposing
well i i think the health care industry
probably is among the the most
impacted
uh industries right now obviously in the
state as it relates to being able to
recruit and retain workforce i do think
that this would be a very popular
program for those industries
i'm also aware that
this is foundational in nature as i had
mentioned
there are
i think other opportunities to continue
to find ways to specifically target
industries such as healthcare but we've
sort of brought this forward in a pilot
sort of format in order to be able to
determine the workability of this and
the effectiveness of it
before we started targeting specific
industries
thank you
but this is
one time money isn't it it's 17 million
so it's a pilot
but how would you propose
funding it on an ongoing basis
if a thousand students or 1500 students
cost 17 million dollars once
well i mean senator that would be part
of the ongoing policy
decision making that we'd all be making
looking forward this is you know this is
something the legislature has looked at
in the past in previous iterations a
version of this type of
program
and whether that is worthy of ongoing
additional federal investment assuming
if you know because the harpa funds are
still available through the end of 2024
if we wanted to make more investments of
those funds or if we wanted to find some
availability of in-state funds to
continue that program that's a decision
that we would all have to make at that
point
i have two more questions
can i hang on hang on just a moment
ma'am i'm sorry there are no
nothing can be raised above your head
it doesn't matter
thank you
thank you madam chair
go ahead thank you
um how
how long a work commitment are you
proposing will it be similar to the
state loan repayment program it's four
years would be the total commitment
under the program
finally
how
how are you going to measure success
what
specific parameters do you have
well i think first and foremost would of
course be the number of employees that
are still in the program at the end of
the program i think it's pretty
common
assessment
in the workforce area that if you're
able to hold on to an individual for a
period of three plus years
generally they their inclination is to
stay with that employer with in the area
that they're in
so that's a little bit of the thought
process there and we'll see or when we
get to the end of this where things
stand
thank you are there any further
questions yes representative leishman
thanks madam chair and just a follow-up
to uh senator rosenwald's question
you say in here and i was a little
puzzled by your response that you're not
quite sure who may be administering this
but you
point out that you intend to partner
with another agency or entity could you
tell us
who that might be his business finance
administration bfa would be the
administrator of this program
okay thank you madam chair thank you
are there any further questions
yes senator gaiden thank you madam chair
could you go into some depth about what
you mean by disproportionately affected
by covid
well i can let chase uh get into that a
little bit more but it has to do with
the federal eligibility components of
the funding that we're using for this
program
you could just press it once there we go
senator guida yes the
disproportionately impacted standard is
established by the american rescue plan
act um and the
targeting of this
fund to those at a certain percentage or
lower of the ami helps meet that
criteria
follow-up ami meaning adjusted median
income area media
okay
follow-up yes
so
what we're establishing here
is an incentive
i mean the commissioner can also jump in
but i think it's an incentive more
focused on student debt relief needs as
opposed to specifically income it's just
meet certain requirements or eligibility
standards for use of these funds it's
it's
called upon entities or states like ours
to have
requirements or areas of focus like this
when using these funds in this fashion
follow-up yes thank you so excuse me
could you move your microphone closer
there there seem to be some issues with
hearing okay thank you
thank you madam chair
so
supposing a person
takes these funds for a year or two of
college and then decides not to finish
is there any mechanism in place to re to
claw those back or have we just wasted
the money
so i think the details of the program uh
some of you worked out with bfa as we
move forward but the current thinking
is to not necessarily advance funds
before reaching certain milestones of
work eligibility so the hope would be to
avoid having to claw back funds based on
how the program itself would be
structured
thank you madam chair
senator daniels
thank you
i just want to express some concerns
that i have and commissioner i know that
you were part of a study committee a
couple terms
ago by over
100 training
courses
i go around now and there are help
wanted signs everywhere
for employers this program is
specifically designated towards the
latter we're
we're hoping to be able to do is attract
students
people who have received certifications
or degrees either here in new hampshire
or elsewhere to come here and take jobs
with new hampshire employers in order to
get this fund these funding you have to
demonstrate that you've taken a job with
a new hampshire employer and that
you've been able to in that you've
stayed in that job during the period the
term of the of the benefit
so it's aimed at specifically getting
people here to fill a lot of those jobs
and you know when we look at um the
demographics the long-term uh
sustainability of a workforce there is
obviously um an inclination for towards
people who are early at earlier stages
in their careers so that's sort of the
thought process with this particular
program i know on the on the training
stuff we you and i have spoken about
that over many years
there may be some programs that we are
able to design and bring forward
and we can have that discussion at that
point as to how we want to handle that
in sort of concert with other programs
that are already existing in the state
follow up yes go ahead uh in finance we
seem to have an unwritten rule that we
do not use one-time money for operating
costs
the money that you're talking about is
basically a four-year
program
and then
people go so so where is the
sustainability
in keeping people in that job if you're
not going to go back to the federal pool
or the state pool for more for more
money to supplement what an employer is
getting yeah i i i
true i think that the point though is
that and what we expect with this
program
is that we would see obligation of these
resources pretty quickly
i think that it would be a popular
program to be able to help students
and adults in a lot of cases offset or
reduce the debt load that they're
carrying in exchange for taking a job
for a period of time in new hampshire
i would expect that most of these
resources would be used up before the
end of 2022
and that we would just be managing the
program
as it is right now going forward over
the next four years as i mentioned to
senator rosenwald if at the end of that
period of time it's the decision of all
of us
to continue some version of this we
would have to find resources that are
available to us to continue it or not
but there wouldn't be any ongoing cost
necessarily beyond the reimbursements
that would happen in processing those
reimbursements for the people who apply
for and receive the funding in 2022.
one final question yes go ahead um so so
why should people be entitled to student
debt relief
now
but those who graduated say last year or
the year before or those who are
graduating three or four years from now
won't be able for won't be
eligible for it
agree and this is one of those programs
where we absolutely cannot design a
program that's all things to all people
i think what we're trying to do is
demonstrate that a program that has a
student debt relief component to it tied
to a work requirement in new hampshire
would uh would provide enough of an
impetus to get somewhere between 1 000
and 1500 new non-existent workers into
the state
employment system
okay are there any further questions
senator guida oh i'm sorry senator guida
i'm over in the corner here matt i know
i know well you had your chance before
right thank you
so a question
as to why businesses themselves
can't provide incentives to employers it
seems to me as though with this program
the government is stepping in to pay the
costs that businesses traditionally pay
for recruiting their own workers and for
that reason i'm i'm prone to object to
it
i i think that that may be the case with
a lot of employers a lot of larger
employers i am aware of are doing some
pretty substantial things to attract
workforce including relocation costs and
so on and so forth but i don't think
that's universally the case with all
employers in the state and a lot of our
employers are as you as you well know
senators smaller employers who may not
have the resources at this point in time
given what we've been through over the
last year or so to be able to make that
investment but they still need the uh
the resources they still need that staff
as a resource to continue to advance
their their business
so at this point it does seem like it
would be a a good moment in time if
there were one to make an investment
such as this
yes you may i would submit that
if we have a four year or two year
training program that an employer has a
need for an employee now that this is
not going to help the situation it's
intended to based on the covered
pandemics we expect to end at some point
so there's a disconnect for me in four
years or two years down the road paying
for a college or an associate degree or
a technical degree
for a need that's now that an employer
will benefit from two or four years down
the road well just to clarify this would
be this would be for students right now
and they would enter the workforce and
then over a period of four years there
would be a reimbursement on an annual
basis basis to those
employees or to to the debt holders
for that
for the in exchange for their employment
final question yes so what do we then
tell those who attempt to qualify and
don't
that because for some arbitrary reason
you're going to have to pay back your
college loan
but because we chose somebody
that's i mean again this is a program
and one of those programs where there's
probably not enough money
in terms of student debt that's out
there right now particularly in new
hampshire to cover every single
senator rosenwald thank you madam chair
i don't feel that i have enough
information to vote on this item one way
or another so i'd like to move that
we've laid on the table
and asked the department
or gopher to come back
at the next meeting with a fleshed-out
plan including sustainability
projections
i'll second the motion to table okay
senator rosenwald moves to table
representative
edwards
seconds
all right you ready
okay the clerk call the roll please
this is the roll call on
21-357 for a tabling motion
representative edwards yes clerk voces
representative irv yes
representative leishman yes
senator daniels yes
senator morse yes senator gaida
no rosenwald yes
senator d'alessandro yes representative
umberger yes
man i'm sure the vote is nine to one
vote on fis 21 357
so could i have a motion to accept the
remaining
items on the consent calendar
under tab 10. move the items thank you
senator d'alessandro moves
senator senator rosenwald's second
all those in favor please raise your
hand
10-0
mr kane
is the late item in tab
10 or tab 11.
there are no positions uh so 21 361 is a
request of 8 million
of arpa funds for the purpose of testing
but
you could take it up now
if you would like
because it is appropriate
okay
all right we will um
yeah did no yes we did vote on the
consent calendars right yes okay thank
you all right
um
fis3
uh 21
they decided that they wanted to do it
now
it's currently located in your books
under
tab
11.
okay
fis
321-361
is from the
department of health and human services
and the purpose of this is to
respond to public health emergency
or its negative in
economic impacts
are there
does are there any questions for
the department
manager
uh
you're saying it's in tab 11 and i don't
have it in tab 11. nor i
um
so it is the late item so depending on
the pre-fiscal meeting um
they were put in that tab it is a late
item which is separate it's 21-361 i do
have a copy if you need it
representative edwards uh thank you mr
cain i
i'm i'm a little reluctant to take this
item up if it's a late item
simply because of
the very recent history of the executive
council
adding a controversial late item to
bypass public notice
and
if we don't need to uh discuss this
today if you will
excuse me please
this was an error on the part of das
this was into das in plenty of time it
got
shuffled under some paperwork which i
can't imagine dis having any paperwork
but the result was
that it
had to enter
our agenda as a late item
because of the problems encountered in
das
hhs had in fact sent this over
in plenty of time
and it was um
it was
basically uh an administrative error on
the part of das as to why it is a late
item
it was not a late
what what we would
yeah it was not a late submittal it went
acted on it because of that so
thank you so so madam chair is is that
is it your position that uh because it
was an administrative error there's no
public interest in having received due
notice of this voting item
i believe this was posted on the
um
website
on what day
um i'd have to go back with
the beginning of this week
my guess is on tuesday it was posted to
under late items and additional
information on the lba website which is
the second column in that grid correct
okay thank you
question
uh yes is this a question for
okay well the folks from hhs no it's
this question for either mr kane or
yours oh okay i'm sorry procedurally so
does that posting on tuesday comply with
the state laws for giving due notice to
the public
it does thank you
i would move the item okay thank you
well we have a motion to table
right did you make that motion
or not being informed that this has been
legally noticed uh i'll withdraw my
tabling motion thank you i would move
the item okay senator d'alessandro moves
do i have a second second
senator rosenwald seconds
okay now we have a question if we could
uh
uh yes senator daniels thank you
being that these are 100 percent federal
funds
what are the restrictions
or the strings attached to taking this
money and in particular on
uh information that has to be reported
back to the federal government
so these funds are 100 arpa funds and if
i might also mention the purpose of this
is exactly the same purpose as the fema
item that was approved earlier these
funds are for the contract for the at
home testing
these are arpa funds that are coming
from gopher so i believe that um all of
the details on the federal requirements
have been provided by gopher previously
but these are the funds that
are more the generalized funds that
were granted to the state and go for
manages and distributes
yes
correct me if i'm wrong but the 2.7
million that we previously approved was
actually in an agency transfer it wasn't
it wasn't
it didn't state that it was 100 federal
funds it stated it was an agency
transfer yes so those are fema funds
which are federal funds but they come to
us through the department of safety so
they are um labeled as interagency funds
but they are federal funds
to the department of safety and
interagency to us thank you
seeing none uh will the clerk call the
roll oh wait do i have a motion
yes yes
okay
21-361
representative edwards
yes
clerk votes yes representative earth yes
representative leishman yes
senator daniels yes senator morris yes
senator gaida yes
senator rosenwald yes
senator del sandro yes
madam chair the vote is 10-0 i'm sorry
that's okay
the vote is ten in favor none opposed
okay now we'll move to um
okay well you told me it was under 10.
so it doesn't matter
all right so now
now we are in uh tab 11.
and um
i would like a motion
that
i'd like a motion to concur
with
fis21
and 21 250
3.
i got to get my eyes checked
on the consent calendar so move madame
cheer thank you representative leishman
do i have a second second
seconded by senator daniels what was the
motion
to accept
three and three five zero yes
all those in favor please raise your
hand
ten zero
okay
we now move to
under tab 11
fis 21
from the
department of health and human services
so if i could ask the
folks from
health and human services to come
forward
okay
all right
okay um
i will
take the uh
minutes that i am the one that requested
removal
so if i could i would like you to please
re-introduce yourselves
dhhs good morning this is patricia
tilley i'm the director of the division
of public health services in the
department of health and human services
thank you lori shibanak commissioner
all right thank you i believe that we
have a
a number of questions dealing with
this particular request so who would
representative leitchman thanks madam
chair uh
first i'd like to thank you folks for
the detailed explanation
that was provided i know in the past
we've been somewhat critical in not
getting all the information from
different agencies but this is a good
example of how it should be done
so thank you for that
but going through it
i did have a question on page three
what is a sub-recipient
what is that i didn't see it in your
handle maybe i skipped it but what is
that specifically sure
so sub-recipient monitoring is when we
provide funds to
to a contractor and they are acting on
our behalf
and the federal government requires us
to monitor
those contractors differently than
say a contractor that we ask to paint a
wall
so somebody that's delivering services
that are statutorily required by our
department or
are federally required by our department
uh to provide um that those are
sub-recipient
um
contractors thanks you're welcome that's
all i have for the moment man i'm sure
thank you are there any further
questions
i i have a few representative edwards uh
thank you
um i want to talk about um the vaccine
registry and i want to talk about it in
the context of
what hhs oversight produced on november
1st relative to
a request of
dhhs
to um to do privacy impact assessments
on critical information systems
there's a tremendous amount of public
interest in what we're going to be doing
with this
registry
and so i i'd like to ask
if the department has undertaken
the development of a privacy impact
thank you thank you representative
edwards so we have not currently begun
that particular process to do a privacy
impact assessment on the immunization
information system which we also call
the registry i will note however that
the development of both the statute that
authorizes the immunization information
system and its administrative rules have
been a long time in development over 10
years over a decade of work has gone
into the development of both the statute
and the rules we're certainly happy to
um look at those other requirements as
recommended at you're here at your
committee but we have not done that to
date
uh is the system set up so that it'll be
an uh an opt out or uh must it be an
opt-in
it is currently and as as per the
statute is currently an opt-out
system
okay so for all those people who are
deeply offended by an opt-out
procedure it's just something we have to
accept if we go ahead and fund this
currently that the way the system is
developed we we operate it fully within
the context of the law that it is is
authorized in you know i will note that
our opt-out system acts very much like
an opt-in in other states that have have
thought about opt-in because we do
require to be notified when you
when information is going to be put into
the registry the provider is supposed to
notify the patient and provide an
opportunity for them to opt out at that
moment
can i make a request that if we approve
these funds that you'll um
work with mr weeders to
to figure out
how we could do a pro
sound privacy impact assessment on the
vaccine registry i i would i would
appreciate your commitment to it
because i i do think it's a vital piece
of public transparency
and chair veteran chair a point of order
yes in a recent letter from the attorney
general we are not allowed to exact
conditions on the approval of
disapproval of fiscal funds through this
committee
and so therefore while i respect what
representative edwards is trying to do i
so would you like them to refuse my
pleasant request senator
i think you cannot conditionalize a vote
on a condition that we establish as a
council okay okay
i did not i'm sorry i did not take that
as a conditional
comment
i think from my perspective he was
simply asking dhhs if in fact they would
do this privacy study
is that correct or incorrect yes it
wasn't a condition it was just saying if
we passed this could would they be open
to committing
to doing a privacy impact assessment
thank you if i may madam chair well
noted
if we pass this indicates conditional
thank you
okay
so we will send the request from
division three
after
whatever happens with this vote
thank you
and then just to make sure uh the public
understands uh how the money is going to
be used to enhance the registry
um
i i understand there's a a couple of
main things that takes place with the
registry one
is it seems like it's a vital inventory
tracking system to make sure that
the vaccine supply that's in the state
we know where it's at we know how it's
being maintained we understand
expiration dates
we
we we can track
shipment from point a to point b within
the state we
can determine our consumption rates and
our waste rates
that that that that's a big part of what
this registry does is it not that is
correct it really is an accountability
mechanism on our part um we are
accountable for vaccine that we receive
directly from the federal government or
from other
entities and then we hold in turn when
we provide vaccine to a provider's
office say a pediatrician's office we
also hold them accountable for that
vaccine as well and this is the system
that does that efficiently if we didn't
have this i.t system and we've not since
what
what would we be doing what what kind of
waste
would there be in the system if we were
unable to to
track it properly certainly so there's
certainly waste in terms of
paper
is one of the big ways that we have been
moving we've been
running the program
for a very long time for immunization is
really paper records moving back and
forth and i think many of us would agree
that that is currently inefficient right
now with most of our providers who have
electronic health records or electronic
medical records ehrs emrs they're
putting that information in their system
it would be more efficient for them to
then have a connectivity to our
immunization information system that's
something called an hl7 i'm not i don't
have the same technical expertise as you
representative edwards but i know enough
that that allows one system to be able
to talk to another system in the most
secure and accurate way and that is
what much of this funds is going to
right now or what we would hope to is to
be able to help that connectivity so
that we can get information efficiently
effectively and securely between
entities
i have more follow-ups i'm sorry i
should have been asking each time let's
um let's let's someone else and then
i'll come back to representative edwards
okay i have about just so you know i
have like three or four or more on the
tax registry that's fine
are there any other questions uh
senator morris
madam chair i i've participated in three
meetings this week and
i thought we were going to start this
meeting today with a presentation by the
department
one of those meetings after everyone
submitted questions was very helpful
in understanding
the two parts the 18 million dollars
number one on the contracts um so it may
answer a bunch of these questions if
thank you so thank you senator morris so
yep no no no problem
great i
okay yes please go ahead great thank you
thank you chair um so i think what i
could do is provide a very basic
overview and i appreciate the question
senator remorse this funding really does
four major things it provides some staff
to the department of health and human
services to manage the grant
do a little bit of communications a
little program management but more
importantly it provides 10 individuals
to help us with our data
and those individuals are going to be
working directly with our pharmacies
with our healthcare providers as they
onboard this connectivity to our
immunization information system the iis
or the registry did you just say just
explain what you mean by on board sure
right thank you not everyone understands
that term thank you thank you for the
for the question and the request for
clarification so onboarding is a process
by which we ensure and test whether
system a at a pharmacy at a healthcare
provider
is sending the information it's supposed
to send to our system and this is
actually quite a long process sometimes
it takes several months to get that done
because it's a process of testing back
and forth we review the data we make
sure the data is accurate on each side
um most again as we know 50 49 other
states in the country have some sort of
registry and their experience is that
this typically takes several years to be
able to onboard all of their providers
in the community unfortunately in our
case when we were ready to go after our
statute was in place our rules were in
place
we were hit with sort of a one-two punch
we were ready to go with our registry
and we were hit with a covid19 pandemic
at the same exact time so the urgency of
our work is greater than ever so that is
what onboarding is it's the process of
data testing where we work intensively
with folks on our in the department of
health and human services with the it
specialists in a number of providers
offices we've provided this committee
with a list of over 400 different health
care providers that we are anticipating
working with
so that's what one of the components of
this funding will do is to provide us
with that staff it's temporary staff we
anticipate needing them for up to about
36 months most of them will
hopefully as we finish that onboarding
process we will no longer have the need
for that same number of staff moving
forward
the second thing that this
funding does is it provides funding for
actually data system enhancements so
again we talked a little bit about hl7
that onboarding process so it provides
some funding for that it also provides
funding for data enhancements for things
like managing temperature control you
know ensuring that we've really got a
good bead and we can be accountable on
not wasting any of the vital vaccine
that we have again this is not only
covid19 vaccine we're also talking about
a vaccine for basic childhood
immunizations polio measles mumps the
sort of infectious diseases that most of
us have never really encountered because
of the effectiveness of vaccine it will
also do data enhancements that will help
providers or people out in the community
folks like school nurses school nurses
will have the opportunity to have a
special module that they can use because
they are required to and mandated by law
to ensure immunization of the students
in their schools or that at least we
have record of that immunization this
will we one of the pieces we hope to
fund would be a portal specifically for
school nurses so they they can see
just their
student population as mandated by the
statute and by rules
the third thing that this funding does
is it puts resources directly into the
hands of our health care providers there
are resources available for hospitals
there are resources available for
unaffiliated health care practices we
had had a question from the committee
about what does the new hampshire
medical society have to do with this and
so we have
determined that we would like to work
closely with the medical society so that
they in turn could work with those
unaffiliated practices those practices
that are not part of big hospital
systems we're going to be working with
those big hospital systems and we're
going to also be working with other
pharmacies and others to ensure that
they have the resources they need to be
able to administer vaccine
do the i.t work on their end with their
ehrs and ensure the accountability of
that vaccine again things like
refrigerators temps managing that within
their offices
the fourth thing that this
project does or these funds will do for
us is a little bit of education and
that's education and ongoing
communications over the course of the
next three years some of that is
peer-to-peer learning
between physicians and other physicians
so that they can share information more
effectively as many people know we
currently at the department do we
twice monthly calls with our providers
we think moving forward over the next
few years some of that work will be
better done from physician to physician
through dartmouth or another entity so
we would like to support that we also
have additional funds to doing other
communications so that we can provide
educational materials to our healthcare
providers that are available in all the
languages they need them to be and that
address the questions that i know many
people in the public have so i think
that's a high overview of the four main
thank you very much
so
were there any other questions other
than the follow-ups that representative
madam chair i would at the end of the
question period like to make a statement
okay fine
representative
thank you madam chair
can you point me to where in the
rsa141c20f
that it says it must be an opt
out system when i read this the registry
that law from 1998 it doesn't seem to
um i don't have the statute in front of
me right now i have the rules in front
of us where it does speak to that
i understand the rules state that very
clearly but the rules are not the
legislation could you clarify where in
the statute it says
if i can pull up the statute in a minute
i can help point you to that i just
don't have it in front of me
take your time no problem i
i'm not sure that i have the statute in
front of me as i look through my notes
oh okay
if you have it on your computer i'd be
happy to look at it
if that's okay with the chair that's
uh you can just come up
oh
yeah
we're not going to let her go away with
do you have other questions that we can
answer while i'm looking this up
oh i think it's right there on the
screen
no any other question so i can take a
minute to read that's why i was asking
okay
is
so
roman numeral 6c and that's what i was
just looking it is the procedures for
the patient or the patient's parent or
garden if the patient is a minor to
decline to participate in the registry
that is what we have interpreted as an
opt-out
fair enough i guess i'd like to and not
now but i'd like to hear that from an
attorney because it seems to me that the
primary
place it's okay
the primary place where your
uh
where that came in was in the rule
making
and i totally agree that that's in the
rule-making but if it really is just in
the rule-making then it would possibly
be possible for you to change that
without any legislation
okay we'll um
i would need i we would need an attorney
and council to tell us that
okay
all right um anything else from anyone
so jess you had i'm sorry
representative edwards you had some
additional questions i i do thank thank
you so much
so um
okay so as representative irv kind of
kicked off the the next area i wanted to
get into about the vax registry
and that is um
i i
this is the the portion of the registry
that has the public the most interested
and to some extent upset is they believe
that
there was a requirement for us to
collect some personal data and to travel
transfer that personal data to the
federal government and there's a this
lingering perception
that
we opted to over collect
personal data
well beyond what the federal
government's requirements were and so
the belief is that new hampshire
is
surrendering
patient privacy that we really had no
requirement to do so
and i was wondering if you could speak
to that
of whether or not we are strictly
limiting the collection and transfer to
the minimum essential data set required
by federal statute
or alternatively
have we decided
individually to enhance that data
collection
thank you for that question so um in
terms of what we send to the cdc
specifically around covet 19 we actually
sent aggregate data they have asked us
for individual line level data we as the
department of health and human services
have sent them aggregate data so in fact
less information than the federal
government required
so so could thank you for that could you
speak to the other part of it though
which is um are are we in our database
uh intending to collect more data
that's then what's required by the
federal mandate
are we for our own purposes are we over
collecting
are you asking in terms of are we over
collecting for the information that we
need here within the department of
health and human services not that we're
sending out is that i'm trying to
clarify basically
you're saying what we need i i always
say what we want but it's a semantic
great um i would have to i'm not
prepared right now to do a line by line
of all of the data elements um i'm happy
to do that if we had had that question
earlier i could have been well prepared
for that sure i've been sick sorry
um
one more set okay
this is about the um
as you know i
it's it's been my point of view
that we have a severe workforce shortage
in new hampshire
and already today we've approved four or
five additional slots for the department
and here's a big chunk of um of 13 more
people
and it just brings up questions to me of
uh where are we going to get these
people
can we really get them should we should
we be trying to pull people out of the
private sector now and putting them into
government bureaucracy jobs we don't
need a
lecture or just what is your question
please
so my question is mr kane would you help
me form a tabling motion to
table the uh 13 positions that are
in this
sure so
um a couple options available to the
committee for motions if it was the
intent of the member to
pass the funding but not the positions
they would move to adopt uh 353 item one
only and to deny
item two which establishes the positions
okay so i would like to move
that the committee adopt item one on 353
and not item two
and i can speak to that motion okay i
seeing none
oh okay uh
senator morris seconds
you may speak to your motion
okay uh madam chair that this is uh
this is representative of a
long-standing issue um with
our workforce crisis here in new
hampshire i i
i just see that we keep
adding more and more and more
bodies
uh on paper
where i just don't know where we're
going to get them from and even if we
can get them i think we're doing damage
to the private sector by pulling human
resources into the government
so
rather than
commit to bringing in yet another 13
people i would just assume
let
the money that would be allocated for
those people be used for the other
programmatics i'm not saying we should
cut the money but i am saying that
there's uh i'm i'm i'm not enthusiastic
at all about
um
adding 13 more people at this point
thank you are there any
are there any other any other discussion
on this
representative senator morris
in fairness to the representative he
brought this up to me earlier today
and i do have concerns about vacancies
in all our departments not just this
department um and and i said that to the
representative and i said i think that's
something that the legislature is going
to have to address in january
um
because
if we have a 15 vacancy running in
health and human services
um
that's a lot of money
um and you know we could have wrote the
check for this quite honestly but i
think that's something the legislature
definitely has to come back
and look at as we get into january
along with the fact that i've asked for
a look at the cafe to see how much money
is left over from last year that i want
to talk about
you're headed down the same pike that i
think the senate would go down
i'm not sure i accomplished anything by
supporting you on not putting these 13
positions in when we're talking about 3
000 positions jess that's the only thing
so
um
i guess at this point i'm not prepared
to go with that motion
i i appreciate that i just am a believer
that uh when you're in a hole you just
are there any other comments
on this particular motion
okay can i ask for an explanation
for mr kane so does this mean that we
are
if this passes
we'd be accepting part one
and not part two now it may be a final
vote on the whole package that is
correct
thank you
wait
madam chair
can i withdraw my second and that'll
okay senator morris withdrew his second
so
um
senator gaida did you want to
say whatever you wanted to say now
i think that would be appropriate madam
chairman okay thank you and i thank the
committee for its indulgence
president ronald reagan once said that
freedom is never more than one
generation from extinction
we didn't pass it to our children in the
bloodstream it must be fought for
protected and handed out
for them to do the same or one day we'll
spend our sunset years telling our
children and our children's children
what it was once like in the united
states
where men were free
this fiscal committee item has
precipitated an incredible amount of
public sentiment in opposition
and it may well be a defining vote for
those in elected office those on this
committee
and is therefore deserving of our most
careful scrutiny
the department is doing what it believes
it must do
its mission and i quote is to join
communities and families in providing
opportunities for citizens to achieve
health and independence end quote
and its intentions are understandable
but we are not the department
we are the elected representatives
of a people that entrust to us their
freedom
and the freedom of their children
and to future generations
of people in new hampshire
as with all of us my mission is and i
quote
to faithfully and impartially discharge
and perform all duties incumbent on me
as a state senator
according to the best of my abilities
agreeably to the rules and regulations
of this constitution and the laws of the
state of new hampshire so help me god
to us falls the obligation of holding
government accountable
of protecting and defending first and
foremost the freedom of our citizens
against the inevitable erosion that
government is capable of producing
no matter the beneficence of its
intentions
our founding president george washington
made the statement
government is like fire
it's a wonderful servant but a terrible
master
implicit in that statement is something
that we as legislators often forget
okay
whether a program infringes on the
natural and constitutional rights of our
citizens but we as elected guardians of
the right to life liberty and pursuit of
happiness
bear the grave responsibility not only
to look at the efficacy of programs
but their actual and potential impact on
the freedom of this and future
generations
before us today is an item in which the
contract under consideration clearly
articulates that the federal government
can and at an indeterminate time in the
future
may impose limitations and conditions on
this government and the people of new
hampshire
with all due respect to the opinion of
attorney general formella a
distinguished legal scholar i'm sure
that the terms of the contract under
consideration are not enforceable
and aware of the legal impotence of the
non-binding resolution adopted by the
executive council it falls to this
committee
today
to weigh the potential benefit
of increased government efficiency
in managing the details of an executive
order
that is under review for its
constitutionality
and the constitutional rights
of that order as they affect the
citizens of our state i have served my
country as an officer of marines in
places you cannot
mention
places you cannot pronounce
okay and done things in the interests of
our country i've served as an fbi agent
i have seen the abuses that government
i had the privilege of
captaining incredible engines of
commerce around the world i have been in
china i've been in hong kong i've been
in pakistan i've been in venezuela i've
been in all the places
where government has gradually and
ultimately completely encroached and
destroyed the liberty of its citizens
i've been in china where the government
monitors and assesses the worthiness of
citizens to partake in the benefits it
doles out to them
where it decides whether or not citizens
are deserving of employment
whether it decides how many children a
family may bring into the world where it
controls every aspect of the lives of
the people over which it rules
we'd like to believe our government our
federal government specifically wouldn't
do such things
our federal government would never
weaponize the irs to audit those who
differ in their political views
but it did
our federal government would never order
a sniper to murder vicki weaver an
unarmed woman with a child in her arms
based on warrants that would replete
with misinformation but it did
our federal government would never
ambush and kill a non-violent man
driving to meet a sheriff in the mahler
national forest
but it did
and our federal government would never
threaten to weaponize the fbi against
parents who want their children educated
and not indoctrinated
but it did
our federal government would never force
a person to take an experimental
injection against their will as a
condition of employment or continued
service in the military but it did
the contract before us states that data
collected by the state is de-identified
and aggregated before being sent to the
federal government
but we have to ask ourselves in the
first instance
why is the state government even
collecting this data individually
identifiable to begin with
and why are the private entities giving
automatically sending detailed personal
data to the federal government
under the terms of the grant under
consideration the department states the
data is de-identified and aggravated
i agree
but under the terms of this very same
agreement
the protection remains only until the
cdc or another federal entity requires
the disclosure of that identifiable data
at some point in the future and for some
purpose unknown to us and utterly beyond
our control
i have no problem with what we're trying
to do i have a problem with the federal
government and the contract that's that
will be signed as a part of this grant
gives them unquestionably the authority
to change the rules without our word out
of us
the action we take today will be
historic
it will be historic because we will
either reject the notion of subservience
to government coercion
or will be historic because we exceed to
that notion and violate the most
fundamental premises of freedom upon
which our state and nation were founded
and which are imperiled as never before
us in our nation's history
i think you have a sense of where i'm
going to vote on this
and i thank you for the indulgence of
providing me the opportunity to speak
madam chair you're quite welcome
[Music]
uh there will be
there will be no outburst from the
audience
okay
so if you would
quieting down
okay
are there
thank you madam chair
of the five to 600 email that i have
received on this item 84 percent
were against it and they were against it
for primarily two reasons
one of them was the sharing of data the
collection of data not knowing where
it's going to go and through just the
discussions we've heard today
no
the it would be
known by the contractor the state the
cdc and even private organization like
the medical society
the problem is
that when government at any level starts
collecting our data
we tend to lose our individual
sovereignty
and
therefore we begin to disrupt distrust
the government that's supposed to be
working for us
to to carry on
we also are asked
to sign this contract
it's a blank piece of paper
that that says
that you are agreeing to
whatever
we
we the federal government are dictating
now and in the future
we don't know what that's going to be
that's exactly the reason we turned this
down two months ago there is nothing in
this proposal that has changed from two
months ago except that you're adding one
more position as a program manager
i don't think there's anyone in here
that would responsibly sign a piece of
paper for a job or anything else
not knowing
what is going to be written on there
that you're going to be held committed
to
for that reason i will be voting against
this i don't see any reason
that we i should change my vote from
what it was two months ago
when we tabled it
i was hoping to get
more information
particularly
i believe a comment was raised before
we'll take the language out
and
the answer was we can't do that because
it's federal language
we have a letter from the attorney
general saying that well the language in
there doesn't mean what it means
we treated every piece of legislation in
the same way then what are we doing
by passing legislation and somebody
interpreting it that we don't really
mean
what we're saying
so if we're going to get back to basics
and start
putting things and and if it's in black
and white
understanding that that's what it means
and that's what's going to hold up in
the court of law then we ought to be
please i don't want to have to ask you
to leave
okay
uh
represent emmerich uh oh could i i don't
have a mouse i would i would move the
item
who is that i'm sorry senator lou
d'allesandro i move the item thank you
do i have a second second madam chair
okay second from representative leishman
okay
will the clerk please call the
that's the roll call on 21-353
representative edwards no
clerk votes yes
representative earth no
representative leishman yes
senator daniels no
senator morse yes
senator gaida
no
senator rosenwald yes
senator d'alessandro yes
madam chair the vote is six yes and four
no
fis
okay
[Music]
i do not want to have to remove you from
this room
but another outburst
how about that
i can't live here all right thank you um
could i ask protective service to please
okay
we now move on to tab 12. madam chair
yes
might we might we take a five-minute
recess
certainly
okay uh
we'll recess for five minutes please
okay
uh that's enough
i am calling
the fiscal committee back to order we
still have some additional business to
accomplish
the first item on the
since we have uh recessed
is a
fis-21347
which is um
on the use of state tab 12
on the use of state-owned passenger
automobiles
[Music]
are there any questions yes
would it be appropriate to move uh tab
12 13 and 14
at once
because they are such diverse items i
thought it would be better to handle
them separately in case someone has okay
are there any questions on 12
this is the vehicles
okay
all right second madam chair
okay thank you uh the motion was to
accept
was by uh senator d'alessandro
seconded by
uh
a roll call for item 21-347
representative edwards
yes
kirkford yes representative yes
representative leishman yes
senator daniels yes
senator morris yes
senator guydah yes
senator rosenwald yes
senator alessandro yes
representative umberger yes
the next item on the agenda is fis
which is a request from the
fish and game department to
transfer
money move the item
thank you
senator guida moves
senator d'alessandro seconds
will the clerk
roll call on
ffis 21-330
representative erf yes
representative leishman yes
senator daniels yes
senator morse yes
senator gaida yes
senator rosenwald yes
senator d'alessandro yes
representative humberger yes
i'm sure the vote is 10-0
the vote is 10-0
we now move to tab 14
which is
21 344
uh fees for the park system
could i have a motion to accept i would
move it thank you senator d'alessandro
do i have a second
second second by
senator rosenwald
will the clerk please call the roll
madam cheer i just have a
quick comment oh yes okay sorry oh not a
problem i'd just like to say this is
another okay uh could i have someone up
from
oh it's just a
comment on okay
i think this is just another good
example of a good job done as far as a
thorough explanation and thank the
department for that
i agreed wholeheartedly
okay um well the clerk please call the
role
representative edwards
yes
clerk votes yes representative earth yes
representative leishman yes
senator daniels yes senator morse yes
senator gaiba yes
senator rosenwald yes
senator d'alessandro yes
representative
yes
madam chair the vote is 10-0 the vote is
10-0
uh
i need a vote on this one right
yes so under tab 15 is a request by
state treasury to release when available
the college tuition savings plan audit
as well as the 529 so just a motion uh
to approve is appropriate so moved
seconds
representative edwards
yes
clerk votes yes representative earth yes
representative gleasman yes
senator daniels yes
senator morse yes
senator gaida yes
senator rosenwald yes
senator d'alessandro yes
representative umberger uh yes
madam chair the vote is 10-0
we now move to the
information items
commend the department of administrative
services
for fis-21320
which is the quarterly status report of
state fund expenditures in the last
fiscal quarter i thought it was very
clear concise and understandable so
thank you very much for
for that
um
the
uh the other thing that i would like to
do before
i turn this over to anyone that might
have questions
is to uh if you will turn to
tab
there is a
commendation for
our
audit division
from the
national conference of state
legislatures
through its national legislative program
evaluation society
and the lba audit division
uh was issued a certain certificate of
impact
for its 2019 performance audit on the
department of health and human services
therapeutic cannabis program
so i really think that this is a great
recognition
for our lba auditors knowing that they
do a great job
and i just wanted to make sure that
everyone was aware
of the good things that
that our lba does for us and that they
are nationally recognized
[Applause]
um i do
are there any other questions on the
okay i do have one
um
and that is
it's your your dhhs on the um
on your
ch chart i don't know what
what the chart number is but it shows
number of positions filled
and uh
below
2700 on on that
and
it looks like we took a pretty steep
drop
in
at the beginning of the fiscal year
and
my concern is
i think as
representative edwards identified
as
many people sitting here are concerned
that
we're we're not
we're just not able to hire i guess is
the right term unless something has
happened
over the last
three or so months that
obviously this chart ends in july
so if if you could just address what's
going on
with our hiring sure so i guess i would
ask lori weaver to come up to talk a
little bit about hiring um but just a
clarification on the chart uh the
straight line is back from
2018 this chart had not been updated for
years and years and years and
part of
the hb1
legislation that
reduced the number of funded positions
in the department required reporting on
keeping positions under 3 000 filled
positions so i uh brought this chart
back to life and started putting those
numbers on there so that's why you see
that weird drop it it's artificial okay
um the other thing i would just say uh
why while you've given me the
opportunity to senator morris's point
earlier about position labs i don't
think that dhhs will have a lot of
position laps although we do have a lot
of vacant positions because of that
footnote in hb1 that reduced the budget
by 22 million or so
um or over the biennium it was 22
million i believe
um in position laps so i i think that
that is going to be
a majority of our position laps there
will be some and um i think hopefully
the note is still on the cover page i
won't be able to provide lapse
information until january it's it's not
accurate until we have at least six
months of data um so i should have
something
if not for the january meeting i could
report out on it at the january meeting
it'll be on the dashboard for the
madam chair mayor ask your question
on this issue yes okay um thank you very
much
could you could you tell me if
the department has a condition of
employment as requiring the vaccine
and are there any positions for which it
we are not requiring vaccine to be
employed by the department there is a
question mark on some of our uh health
care facilities on whether the cms
mandate is going to
impact them mainly new hampshire
hospital and glencliff home so
as you know and the attorney general
could speak more to this than than
myself but we have signed on to the
lawsuit contesting the mandate both the
cms and the in the um business mandate
um so we're waiting to to get more
information from that lawsuit i i i want
to thank you for everything you're doing
and can still do in the future to
okay please go ahead hello my name is
lori weaver i'm the deputy commissioner
of the department you were asking about
retention and workforce well i'm asking
about hiring hiring yeah i mean i
realize retention goes with it sure
um unfortunately i think we are in the
same boat as many other state
departments and agencies that we face
hiring challenges over the last year
we've had an average of a 20 percent
aggregate so that would be across the
department in all divisions uh 20
vacancy rates so as soon as we fill
positions they may vacate on the other
end we have about 50 percent of our
population in the department of staff is
about
direct care positions so those are folks
that are out in the field servicing our
citizens meeting with families children
adults what have you those have been
particularly hard to fill during the
time of a pandemic a lot of folks don't
want to put themselves at risk
going out into communities and into
homes so
we have we even have vacancies in our
human resources department so even that
has been a challenge we've gotten
creative we've spent some money with
different kinds of recruitment different
kinds of advertising working with
schools and colleges we just did the
manchester community college fair a
couple of months ago recruiting looking
at high school students coming out of
high school and working in the
department
trying to look under every rock possibly
that we can to find people
the thing that keeps people at the
department is that we're a
mission-driven organization so people
come to the department because they want
to serve and they want to
help the citizens of the state and we've
been trying to market that as much as
possible to define those folks too but a
lot of other people are looking for them
as well so we have not given up on our
efforts
but unfortunately as soon as one fills
another one vacates right okay and if i
could just add that 20 includes unfunded
positions thank you karen oh okay
all right are there any other questions
for hhs
i'm sorry
fiscal's not over
madam chair first i'd like to um thank
you i know you've had a very trying week
i've been alongside you in many of those
meetings
to be able to
get the information that we believe we
needed this week
to be able to vote on an item today
so thank you for all that you've done to
get us the answers to questions um
beyond that i'd also like to say i know
the house
faced the same challenge that the senate
faced i i know with senator geiter i was
on the phone with him wednesday night
telling him that if he wanted his vote
represented um you need to get back on a
plane and
he told me he'd let me know that and he
did and he came back here today
and i know in the house they had the
same issue
um
i've i've been very
very
upfront about the fact of what i believe
in in the fiscal committee i mean you
all get a hundred dollars and i get an
extra 25
and we come to this committee and we
actually read this book
and
the reality of it is i think it's made
hhs better i think the presentations
this week have
gone beyond where they normally would be
and i think it made it so that we can
make decisions
but i'd also like to be very clear
i took the same oath to the constitution
of new hampshire
into the
and while i sit here
there is no doubt that when i make
decisions i make them the same way you
do bob
i make them believed on the fact that
i'm doing the right thing
because of my position in the new
hampshire senate and i know you respect
that
and i just want to make that clear
thank you madam chairman
uh senator d'alessandro thank you madam
chair
madam chief i'd like to do two things
first of all i would like to reinforce
what the senate president said
kudos on the way you've handled the
meeting and the way uh your people have
gone through the week in preparation for
this meeting i i'm i'm truly impressed
by the way you handled the crew
so
you get a bonus for that you're not
going to get another 25 bucks because
but if we take up a collection here we
might be able to come up with that
um i take an oath i've been here a long
time
and we all do the best that we can and
we respect everybody else's opinion and
i think that's that's extremely
important
i think communication is the key we've
had better communication i spoke about
communication a couple of meetings ago
and i think it's improved we can do a
much better job if we get good
communication and that means good
information in a timely fashion
that makes us better legislators and i i
think that's worth coming and
it's been part and parcel of the process
and the last thing i i sent you a
notification saying i was going to say
this i talked to
senator daniels about this also i think
when we ask a department head to be here
that department head should be here
uh we need that
senator daniels explained to me why a
particular person wasn't i appreciate
that very much the work that you did
but indeed
the department heads serve the
legislature
when a department head is asked to be
here that department head should be here
people have questions there are times
the only person that can accurately
answer those questions is the department
head
so i i want to make that point emphatic
okay thank you yes
uh i think that
i jumped ahead of myself but
i think that based on your comment
senator that i will delay
the um education
comments from today
and reschedule them for
our next meeting which i believe is
december 17th 17th is the third friday
of december correct
is that okay yes thank you madam i
appreciate that and
i know that our doe folks will take that
message back
and
if there's any question the commissioner
can give me a call
so
is there
any other business that i have managed
to forget just happy thanksgiving
yeah that's it yes happy thanksgiving to
everybody and uh i thank you all for
your hard work and i
i thank our two members that
were so
um
interested in
the topic today that they
cut short their
their vacation time with their family
so i i appreciate that very much so
okay thank you all and uh we'll see you
on
yes
if